こんにちははじめ社長です皆様今ネットでめちゃくちゃ話題になっている伝説の生き物
100日後にシヌゥはにご存知でしょ
多分ツイッターやっている方だったらほぼほとんどの人は知っているところですけど今
めっちゃ twitter で話題になってて何日方だ
もうすぐですよ多分やばい後どうかあと10日で死んじゃいます90日前から
からツイッターのイラストレーターさんが100日後に死ぬマニーという漫画を読ん子
ですなんですけども毎日書き初めてまして
会社の日は1日目って書いたって5万人が普通に生活したんですけど死ぬまであと
100日て語ってえ次の日にはつかめた2シルバーと90クリンチ3日ね死ぬまでと
98979695でカウントダウンが始まってきて3ヶ月経った今
残りがあと10日あと10日で100日後で死ぬまでが新別の状況にありましてどんな
漫画かと言いますとまぁ見てもらったら分かると思うんですけども普通に1人が生活し
てるんですよ
心配なんで僕や見てる方もそうなんです皆心配なんでこんなに元気そうになかっ
恋とかしたりね友達と遊んだりなんかコーチと甘酸っぱいようなけどなんかそんな
決して調理やズってわけでもないんですけどもいい感じで暮らしてるバニーさんが何で
後動画で死んでしまうとか
ほどああ本当に僕結構航路から進んで欲しくないなというのは思ってましてえっ争いだ
が多いと思うし
どうやって死ぬんだろうっていう脳内の妄想が膨らんでくるに大変なっちゃった方が
いいと思って今日はなんと100日後に神沼にの作者ターンと
電話して話してみたいと思いますなんとなくの質問の内容を考えてるんですけども
とりあえず俺は知りたいのはどうせあるを書き始めたのかでどうやって死んじゃうのか
っていうところちょっと聞ければ聞きたいと思うんですよねこの動画でねた場所になり
ますちょっと聞けるところで頑張り話してみたいかなと思っておりますでは早速電話
知ってみようと思います出会いがーっあの漫画カット色
それた最適露木さんってか誰がやってるんですけども喋ったことを全く知らない
でしょうかを何も知らない状況で急にテーマで話し始めるという今日あるよね
それでもボールを終点では行きます
そあご存知数えましたん
気がしちゃってっ
100日後の兄シネは23で俯瞰
今日はすみませんよ直前のでを失礼します1日目からマンゴーを見させていただいて
おります
あの100日後妊娠1に関して菊池さんにお聞きしたい事がございましてん
決して縁にと言わないのでもうあの菊地さんが答えられるところまで教えて頂けると
いう
聞いてくるんですけど切っちゃっておいくつなんですか
のん
あそうなんですね
僕は27年6個さですね
と聞いていきましょう
[音楽]
なぜ100日号西音馬にを書こうと思われたんですか
こうと思ったのか終わり
が死んじゃうんです
そうですねレバームーン
100年後の人
いるし
1年後ました
明日も人気ですし
ね自分は例えば50年後だとして本
今は
煮汁
関わっている人がもし頭走った
御着駅じゃない
状況の中でん
今生きてるわけできな
noa
多可郡
[音楽]
以上の言葉とかもが悪い事とかも
になるんじゃないかなと思って
確かになんかなんだろ100日後に死ぬって分かっててきょうつけないと芯材よって一
かの重みがすごかったんですよ
見え方がすごい変わったなって思いましたらあの漫画の中でどうしてる
1に何ですか
[音楽]
は一強いから
1日使用
7強いのが良かった者ん
をチェックしてほしい
終わりがあるんん
[音楽]
ゆうのほうがいいかななるほどなるほどお客さん愛着が湧いちゃってて
あっつで line スタンプを置かせていただきましたありがとうござい白石
めっちゃかわいいやのぴょろペロペロとか
やってゆく副書記のんいった
あつかないですかそう意味深なシーンが多くてすごい
すべてに意味があるように感じちゃいますめっちゃん
[音楽]
状況等うーん
読者の規定
ほんと機構思ってんのかなとか
帰港したら却下じゃないかなとか
きっかけを作れているので
それぞれかなぁか
あ自分た
たこしようとか君に生活製品
いうかなーと思う
雲布団って届きますか
冒頭熱田カーン
第一年号なので
とに行かないと
ではないと思います
終わっお気に入りのキャラクターは誰ですか
阿部ですはい p
[音楽]
と思うけど参議院
あのドーナツまでですねはじめ
あのチームが好きとか
伊勢成り立たないというか
ありますねなんかあの三位一体感ですよね
元持ちだからナイフ
会わなくなるん
お互いに頭に
言葉の編
では宣吉な最後になるんですけども
一つお聞きしたいことが最後にございまして
ズバリ聞きます
100日後に死ぬ間には
どうやってしますか
はいっ
実は
すううううううっ
うまですかー
なかったん
今んそうだと思っ
はいん
あああ
間には
どうやって死ぬんですか
どのやっぱり作品にデー
欲しいですああああんっ
[音楽]
誰か来ましたねー
ああそうでちょっとまあ卓球日良かったりされません
しないん
日本100時間ぐらい初訪問
今のやつですか決まったらしいですよあっついてねーマジックだだけ使ってますか
キンググループですよあっほんと[ __ ]だから皆に鶴何言われたんでそんな
てますっ
わー空ですね武笠ギネスを使ってます本当に死んじゃうんですか
[音楽]
復刻も死んだし
身長は是如此
まあそれでは命あるものはいつかしていますからねあ
なんだよ
いって考えても
パソコンでも人でも
いって終わりが来ちゃうんです
意識して生きてたら
って方が変わるんじゃないかなと思う
ですよねそんな木草にズバリ聞きます
生きるとはどういうことなんでしょ
[音楽]
んですよん
毎日しっくりきお
[音楽]
me
バッハ
何か喋ってらっしゃるサイトに突然切っちゃうんですけど大丈夫ですか
さぁづととご無礼をお許しくださいすいません企画敵とあなた動画的に最後
機関車流されセットで昨日からトップ9
僕が質問を好きさにして
h さんが答えている間に僕がぷるんってきちゃう感じになると思いますよねそうぞ
炊飯者とご無礼をお許しくださいちゃう
クシャルっている間がいいそうですねって
ここで一旦